[Music]
thanks for coming this is uh ml AI
two-to-three customer stories
transforming businesses with cloud a I
solutions so today we're going to hear
from several three as a matter of fact
Google cloud customers about their own
stories transforming their businesses
using AI and ML technologies on Google
cloud so the speakers today are gonna
come from three different customers
we're gonna start with hearing from
Minori Matsui Matsuda from Nissen then
we're gonna hear from Laura bandura at
Chevron and finally from Justin Hobson
from Hitachi consulting and at the end
of the session there should hopefully be
a little bit of time for QA there is a
Dory for this session as there have been
for many of the other breakouts so if
you go to this link you will be able to
ask questions to the presenters that we
will if we don't get to them at the end
of the session we will make sure to
answer them in the Dory by the end of
the conference so I'm gonna spend just a
few minutes recapping some of the things
that you heard this morning at the
keynote from Rajan Smith a p.m. for a
cloudy eye about cloudy eye solutions
we've announced several new cloudy eye
solutions here and next the idea behind
these solutions is to combine the Google
AI expertise and the products that
you're already familiar with with an
ecosystem of partner services and
partner technology services to enable
the deployment of end-to-end AI
solutions that utilize your data but
that you can plug into your existing
technology and workflows to solve an
end-to-end business problem so let's
let's dig in a little deeper
again the these solutions are targeted
towards all of the verticals that you
here including retail and manufacturing
healthcare media and entertainment and
so on and focus is on not just building
a machine learning model to do
predictions for a particular use case
but rather building an end-to-end
solution that takes the data in pre
processes the data runs it through a
model and then serves those results out
to an end application that you your team
may integrate with to again solve a real
business problem so one of the key new
announcements we've made here next for a
cloudy eye solution is the new document
understanding AI again a comprehensive
solution targeted on document
understanding many different kinds of
documents you allow allow you to extract
insights from these documents and it's
basically a core building block for what
could be an end-to-end solution for
document management document control and
so on in your business we also announced
here at next recommendations ai which is
a state-of-the-art AI service that
allows retail customers to power
recommendations it's a fully managed
service it's very easy to upload your
data to to this service to do the
integration and then you can deliver
those recommendations to any endpoint so
you could integrate them with your
existing website for example and we've
seen dramatic results from our initial
deployments over the past year or year
and a half with several customers in the
retail space including i dropping
numbers like ninety percent lift in
click-through rates and forty percent
lift in conversions and some in some
cases big lifts and revenue as well and
then finally I want to mention the
contact center AAA this was actually
announced at their last next but we
continued to expand and build on this
solution and it's a great example again
of a suite of technologies that's all
oriented towards solving a particular
business problem namely enabling an AI
powered contact center or taking your
existing contact center and injecting it
with AI capabilities
so again this is all part of a very
comprehensive set of tools and building
blocks that we have a now and cloudy eye
including many of the other
announcements we made it here at next
including things like Ottawa mill tables
something that I'm extremely excited
about and AI actually this is AI
platform now I think the name was
changed just before the conference as
well as all of the hardware acceleration
and the frameworks that we support
tensorflow obviously but other common
frameworks for machine learning
including scikit-learn spark and pi
torch as well as a growing ecosystem of
machine learning partners that can help
you build your solution you can work
with Google to deploy the solution or in
many cases Google+ a partner and
yourselves will build the solution
together and again we haven't a very
large and growing set of solution
partners to help you on this journey all
right with that I'm going to introduce
our first customer speaker this is
Minori Matsuda data scientists at Nitin
Minori welcome to stage thank you very
much I today I talk about the
recommendation system on the built on
DCP first of all my amino lee and data
scientists at seven and high holdings
and mainly I'm doing the machine Lonnie
and let me introduce the my company and
our group our group is the one of the
biggest retail in Japan and it's based
on the mail marketing originally and we
are covering most of the household data
in Japan it's over 30 millions household
data in Japan and we are mainly little
in the fashion items this is our company
and put our data
we are processing the natural language
and the product images in the customer
attribution data and the customer
behavior log such as the product
description and the customer label the
natural language processing these are
mainly Japanese in 1 million plus images
in the over 30 million household as I
said and of course we are literally on
the website so we have a website cut
rock and found many transaction data ok
and now we have a three challenges we
had before we use the Google cloud one
is the need to create a model from
scratch so we have many data so leverage
unique product features from the data's
and secondly a giant model in speed we
issue the 5 times per year that the
paper cut rod so we do in modeling by 2
over 200 to bear-bear values and making
a model but it's little slow to adapt to
the website business speed and anomaly
the interoperability of the model and
most of our goal is amande most of the
software package is the black box inside
so I cannot feed back to the business
side explain about motel and the sub is
needed to launch within a human's let's
hope you this is the one of the example
of the image similarity based item
recommendation so technically feature
extracted by convolutional neural
network and doing the unsupervised
learning by tens of Roy the machine will
find the left side that dress and the
right side dress is a similar product
the machine can recognize it and I
showed a little bit interesting video
about this how the Machine recognize
images
I brought 10,000 product images on this
the tensile ball test aborted the
visualization to the floor and as you
can see there are many many product and
I give the task to the machine to
clustering clustering this is the
unsupervised learning and I don't tell
the Machine that this one's a bed and
this one's a shoes I do not tell to the
machine but machine automatically can
classify like this this is the called a
dimension reduction
originally this each point has the 300
dimensional vectors but after that the
machine can recognize that
classification this is the sweater this
is the bed that is a bed
yeah you're like this and also the
machine can understand the as you may
know the language is natural language
such as the word and the document and of
same same as before the giving a task
for unsupervised learning of the natural
language the machine will tell the
lumbago and the posture is similar
languages and it's by the assembling the
data and sampling data this one's hard
to see but we are sampling the two
organisms it's such as the structured
data structure data and DNA and CNN and
what we get from the planning is the
massif ID product affinity by itself and
the Machine can product predict before
selling and become the called the stud
problem such as if the customer has no
data we cannot recommend anything but we
overcome the coaster problem and finally
this is a beyond human understanding if
we teach to the Machine this is the cute
the kawaii is the cute in Japanese the
kawaii we tell what is the how I equated
the cuteness to the machine the machine
will understand the machine will
captured what is the cute the feature of
the cuteness and after machine learned
cuteness as you can see nothing generate
the cute human woman underwear and this
one this product are not existing Liao
under the machine generated and we are
going to sell it in leo in the
competition petition to the against a
human prod product manager
okay then thank you very much thank you
very alright next we have from Chevron
Laura bandura
hello everyone my name is Laura bandura
and I'm a research geophysicist at
Chevron in the oil and gas industry we
have so much data legacy modern data its
sequestered across clouds tapes and
multiple internal file systems and in
some cases even on paper
if we cannot rapidly unearth this
information then the value of this
information is reduced significantly the
large projects that we work on tend to
be very large and very cross functional
they're very global and they require a
large diversity of people with different
technical expertise different languages
and we all and we all work together to
attempt to bring value with all with all
of this diversity in mind and this helps
this ultimately to make better decisions
so just as one would use Google Earth to
explore the subsurface into it to
explore the subsurface and to organize
information on the surface of the earth
we really aim to want to expand this
into an additional dimension in time and
in depth and this is where we utilize
our information and we often work at
multiple time scales where we have the
age of the rocks whoops go back where we
have the age of the rocks which is the
largest time scale that we work at and
even in a much smaller time scale we
have the asset lifetime which can range
from decades to even even a century in
some cases at the most at the most at
the smallest skills then we're looking
at our business processes in real time
and monitoring business operations
around the world but most importantly we
need to access information related to
all acts of access all aspects of our
business both quickly an efficient
me
so now I'd like to introduce you to an
assay a petrol physicists in our San
Joaquin Valley business unit is home to
some of the largest oil fields in the
world
for example Midway sunset oil field is
the third largest in the United States
and the largest in California
it has about 35,000 wells now each one
of those Wells has a paper well file
where critical information about the
well is stored and those can range from
being like fairly small sized sacks of
paper you can go through some of these
pretty quickly to just enormous monsters
full of analysis and data no I don't
usually have to go through the paper
files anymore because most of them have
been scanned so I go through the PDFs by
hand most of the time I know data is
already there I can go and find it um
and then when I find something really
important print it
I also stumble across really interesting
things this is a file from this is a
copy of a record of all of the rocks
that were drilled through from oh well
from 1911 and this is a weakness snarky
letter that somebody wrote about their
samples being mistreated usually when I
find something that I'm going to
actually leave I print it and this is a
real stack that I'm working with
um this is fine so is in suggested we
have an opportunity to improve on how we
access legacy data and documents to
support our decisions now so now let's
take a look at how we've addressed this
challenge with tools on GCP in order to
do in order to dig deeper into the
content of our documents we first need
to break them down into the parts that
can be analyzed in a custom way this
requires each document to be segmented
and then these segments are classified
into either text tables or images and
then we have to order them in order to
holistically put them into context when
a document is classified as an image
such as this one it's important to
extract the labels that are within the
image as well as the details within the
image
in this case we have a geologic model
for some applications it's important for
us to understand those pieces as well as
the whole image itself it's also
important that we capture the
information within tables and to
transform these tables which in
documents are in an are in an
unstructured data format we want to make
we want to put these into a structured
data format so that they can be used by
our analysis tools in a much more
efficient way our documents contain a
variety of image types that are specific
to the geosciences many of which that
you can see here these range from
seismic data to to earth models to
geologic maps and much more some of you
may remember from next next 18 that we
use Auto ml vision to classify these
image with Auto ml it's straightforward
to customize the class efficient the
classification scheme to our earth model
content or science content we simply
upload hundreds of images that we have
on our and then we upload hundreds of
images and then we label them with some
of the image the image labels that you
see here and then within a matter of
minutes we can already have an initial
model that can help us train our all of
our train our model to classify
everything that we have on our system
and then this can be used to make that
content searchable further the auto ml
interface is very easy to use there are
very simple tools that are shown to the
user such as the autumn auto ml
generated confusion matrix right here
this is a very straightforward way that
an an expert in the geosciences can
understand where maybe they may need to
add more training example
to improve the model or make other
changes to increase the accuracy in some
cases maybe they just need to train the
model longer in order to get a better
result but these types of outputs are
very easy for for just normal subject
matter experts in subjects other than
machine learning so technical experts to
use and that's what we find very useful
about Auto ml so as you can see from the
diagram here
Auto ml is not all that we needed in
order to make this work to make
everything searchable so I'm going to
call up Kenson PRNDL to talk about this
in more detail and for the last couple
of years we've had a great partnership
with Google and he has helped us
implement this within our company and
take it away Kenson Thank You Laura
so yes thank you so yes as Laura
mentioned we've been working together
for quite a while now on how to
characterize these documents at a meta
level and then also at a segment level
so as you can see on the left hand side
so first I mentioned that of course this
was last year's information that we
basically built with with Chevron and
essentially we're moving past that quite
aggressively now to sub image
segmentation and she's mentioned before
but also well logs LS files and seg-y
files and our focus here is to actually
connect it all together for true analog
search and so what we're after is stuff
that we can get greater and greater and
deeper insights into the world's data
set not just data assets data set so on
the left hand side you'll see that the
ingestion process is simply just
triggered by emptying your files into a
bucket and the bucket triggers a whole
series of events that automatically
process the data though goes to GCS
storage pub/sub handles all these vents
and moves to cloud dataflow dataflow is
only tasked with one purpose which is to
break it into pages the pages then can
be parallelized
for processing in the segmentation space
right so we go into the page we segment
the page as a human readable flow right
so we we keep all the text we keep all
the images in the right order so that it
was as if humans
the document later in life this would
become evident of why it takes a long
time to do this but we want not only the
semantic expressions of how the document
information flows we want sentiment and
sentiment is very very hard to achieve
without keeping the word flow of the
entire vector space consistent so we're
doing this for some reason later which
we'll talk about and then of course once
we get this information on the segment
level we're actually passing it through
a whole series of api's so these api's
are of course auto about vision NLP and
translation amongst a few others and the
whole point here is we're trying to
figure out with with every one of these
holes whether they're an image a table
an equation a drilling diagram a table
whatever it is text and and so once we
get this we actually run that you know
adaptively through the algorithm to
figure out the information we want off
of it once we do that we actually pass
that into a cloud machine learning
engine called to figure out a word
defect and image Tyvek encoded to do a
model right and so in this case we're
trying to figure out what the type of
the document is so we're not stopping it
just getting the information out for
just general keyword search we're trying
then to go deeper and say well this is a
drilling report or this is a composite
log whatever it is we're trying to make
it easy so you can do filter search as
well as just true vector search from
that point pub/sub delivers that back to
the GCF GS at GCS archive and all of the
segments of interests are saved there
for display and then of course we
indexed those either to cloud search or
elastic search cloud search is our
preferred method because we can scale
much a little more but elastic search
works perfect as well and then of course
we've integrated dialogue flow so that
you can talk to your your interface but
that's not a big focus of this
ultimately what we end up with is the
documents on a map with the ability to
search images or text or images and text
all right so why are we doing all this
we're not just doing it to pull out the
images and pull out this information
we're trying to integrate all the data
right and so on the top you'll see that
we have classic kind of digital data
that we experience a lot we see well
logs and seismic earth models these
things are recently well formatted and
understood and then we're trying to take
the glue between those and the
interpretation are the documents right
they are the two interpretations that
we're actually getting from these
upper-upper images so what we've done
recently which everyone as we've built a
knowledge graph that can handle the
entity resolution and geolocate based on
that resolution so at this point we've
got la s-curves we've got seg-y files
we've got any kind of attribute of any
of those those feature sets and we've
got the documents tied to those features
and a connected similarity in edge 3d
space such as this so you'll see here on
the Left we have this well login seismic
it's pretty obvious when you do this as
a geophysicist that this well log
belongs to this piece of seismic that's
the classic kind of view of this but
when you don't actually have this stuff
into a project it's actually quite hard
to understand where this data is
connected so on the right hand tops you
see the knowledge graph representation
of this and you'll see that we'd have
nice nice knowledge graph nodes
connecting who would be who is the
operator what what did this log and/or
field from the document was an
oil-producing field was it the Scott
field and the point here is now when you
search for these things you're getting
back the analog system not just the data
that you're looking for we get all the
features that belong to that particular
search term if you're looking for a
finite object but then if you look for a
general object like a porous sandstone
of Northwestern Australia for example
you actually might light up a world map
and say here all the triassic sands that
actually have relevant features that are
similar this and that that's kind of our
goal in this space back to Laura
all right so we will this is really just
the beginning for us we started from an
earth science proof-of-concept where we
applied these methods to exploration
asset development and operations but now
we are really on a journey to embracing
the opportunity for impact across our
entire enterprise where we can move to
onto for drilling completions facilities
and health environment and safety so we
see so much hope for this application
and we're looking forward to expanding
it thank you
thank you Laura and Kenton our next and
final speaker is Justin Thompson from
Hitachi I'm sorry Hopson thanks Luckman
as it says here I'm Justin Hopson I'm a
senior data scientist with Hitachi's
consulting division where the
professional services arm and I want to
talk to you today about a customer story
this is something that might be relevant
to some of you in the room for others
you may not be as familiar with this
background we're going to talk about
decent damage from the recent electric
utility fires here in California there
have been impacts here we've had human
fatalities we've had liability
litigation this is something very
important to our community and we saw
this as an opportunity to get involved
and understand what are the historical
patterns that have led to utility caused
fires in particular we're going to focus
on the electrical grid and what were the
conditions that exist prior to fire
ignition and see if we can model where
were those conditions occur again in the
future so that'll be the first part of
this talk I want to go through some of
the data the training and the validation
some of the mapping in the output
and then more importantly can we
actually turn it into action it's great
to have the insight but can you actually
go do something with it to change
people's lives change operational
behavior out in the field so I know I've
got many different people in the
audience some of you want to understand
how did you do it so let's start at the
architecture work our way up so here on
the left some obvious candidates we've
got some batch data had to look at long
term Rick's risk factors things like
drought obvious contributor to
flammability had to look at the
electrical utility assets parts of the
transmission in the distribution grid
what's their age what's their condition
what's been the maintenance on those
assets had to look at the historical
weather where was it windy right where
were there when was it wet and raining
and then of course what we're trying to
predict fires then we also got to work
with some streaming data using pub/sub
in particular we have the utility
management activity right the electrical
grid well it's been around for over a
hundred years in some locations we're
constantly doing work on it we're
changing the quality we're doing
maintenance we're doing repairs and so I
want that information as soon as we can
get it also we've got vegetation
management activity that happens every
single day
we've got crews out trimming trees
looking at the condition in the
right-of-way looking at the condition
adjacent to the right-of-way and then
last I've got the weather forecast
because I want to know what's gonna
happen tomorrow and the day after that
and the week after that so we can ingest
all of that obviously we'd have a
tremendous amount of time series
processing we had to do spun up data
proc was great for that we were storing
results both base data and process data
in cloud storage and then we had a
couple different approaches to our
modeling that evolved over time we had
the cloud ml engine where we're running
some of our models and then also we just
used the cloud data lab it was great for
just getting quick answers and then we
would read all
out into a front end because as a data
scientist I was really happy back here
but for my business users I needed to
publish and it was great that I could
put results in the cloud sequel because
then they could feed it into all kinds
of downstream applications and then I
could put a web UI on the front right I
didn't know who all the users might be
but I knew that I could make it
available to them on the Google cloud
platform this for us was very much a
journey of discovery we did not sit down
in a conference room and say based on
everything we know
let's architect this thing once and I'm
sure we're gonna get it right and I
think you may have heard some of that
and what kenton talked about as well so
a couple things we learned I wanted to
share with you because you may go on a
similar journey one on the left the
architecture we sat down with initial
design our feeling was this is probably
a good start we got started and we
learned we didn't nail it the first time
but there are some great tools out there
in particular the official icons and the
sample diagrams was great as we could
bring in subject matter experts and talk
about the problem talk about the data
talk about the challenges we had and
some of the ETL processes and say does
this feel like something that's been
solved before does Google already have
tools and accelerators that we could use
and the answer was yes also on the
pricing I'm in a professional services
organization people always ask me how
long is it going to take what's it going
to cost and so some of the pricing
wasn't known right the answer as well it
depends how fast you want to go how soon
do you want it so we had some great we
use the pricing calculators that worked
really well because I could then put
that back into my clients hand and say
it's your decision the tools are here
they will support you to do it it's
really what's your budget and what's
your demand in the market also the
inexperience with the new tools the
Google cloud platform continues to
evolve you saw today we've got new tools
available to us there's also been an
evolution of the tools we were using
while we were using them
and that worked really well but it meant
we weren't always experienced so I could
take junior folks and get them involved
build on what they already knew and then
get them deeper into the Google cloud
ecosystem so that was really great for
building morale in the team and
sustaining the energy on this project we
also dealt a lot with the complexity in
building the data science pipelines
there's a lot of math it's complex but
what I found is I could tell people just
go try it just get started I could put
the tools in their hands and it worked
really well they could do prototyping
they could get into sheets we could say
here's what I want to do now I want to
do it even bigger I'm kind of excited
about the auto ml work and some of the
connected sheets stuff we saw today I
might be using that by next week and
then the other thing is because I had a
smaller very high trust team it was
great for me I had great visibility and
my whole team had visibility to each
other's work and so that made it very
efficient if somebody was out or they
had a question how it was done
I could always get to the repository I
could see the work I could see the
workflow and if my leadership wanted to
audit and understand or my client wanted
to dig deeper it's all there for them to
see it's transparent and then the last
part the DevOps basics this stuff will
kill you if you don't think about it
it's a lot harder if you did it the old
way it took a lot of time and money so I
was very excited we felt that natively
building these applications in GCP cut
out a lot of time and cost for those of
you who like the pretty pictures here's
an example on your left of one of our
early models you can see some of the
utility footprint you can see some of
the trees some of the risk factors are
modeled out in the grid and that was
great
we got an answer but of course the very
that very day we read out the results
we've got
I think we've got it I got asked well
hey this is great can we expand the
spatial scope can we build out two
adjacent states can we go to other
utilities and territories because you
know we trade power over them and if
they go down I go down
we got asked for expanded temporal scope
can you take more time how about could
we had more variables oh I've got a
really great idea I met somebody who's
in forestry and he was explaining to me
the physics and how the different
species of trees have different
elasticity's in the wind like hey yes
we're on a platform where we can do that
really what we're left with our business
priorities which one do you want to bite
off first it allowed us to run lots of
model variants as well to explore to the
extent the research was not clear and
there were opportunities for us to work
and expand on some of the research at
the universities had done we were able
to do that and ultimately I'm a business
person could we make it actionable could
we make it easier for the downstream
applications to consume this information
and change the work orders that go out
tomorrow to actually make a difference
out in the world the other piece of this
is really interesting if you come at it
from a policy perspective right so we
put together the model and everybody you
know let's talk about the accuracy and
the precision and the recall let's let's
get into the numbers and that's of
course important obviously along the
diagonal here the true positives right
the ones we got right also important the
true negatives we predicted no fire
there was no fire let's talk about the
off-diagonal this is really interesting
policy discussion in the bottom left
corner we predicted there would be a
fire but in fact there wasn't any so
what's the harm what have we done when
we're wrong in this model I've sent
somebody out to trim trees well the
utilities obligated to go through the
whole territory every year over two
years every four years it depends on the
risk and where you are what the utility
what the regulation is in your state
but really I've maybe accelerated when
we got to it but nobody's been harmed
this is relatively low-cost for
something I was going to do
operationally anyway the top right is
the one you don't want to be wrong
that's what we said I don't I don't
think that's the dangerous one but it
turns out it was so when we got into all
the hyper parameter tuning that's the
one where you said I got to make that
thing as small as possible every dataset
you can give me every transformation you
can think of and I was never limited by
the platform I'm limited by our
imagination by the research and by time
some examples then we also found was
helpful you know got great big datasets
I want to know so where were we right
where were we wrong two examples appear
false positives these are actually kind
of a fun story I was wrong because we
got there early I told you 12 hours
before it failed I thought it was gonna
fail so my mind that's actually a
success story I was I was wrong but the
impact of that is you would have cut it
down and we all be a lot happier and on
the right-hand side some that we got
right not only the location and the time
we understood the conditions and that
made us feel like we've got this this is
good enough that we can start to
operationalize we can roll it out we can
make decisions with this data with this
model with this team so couple takeaways
first we really had a great experience
with the Google cloud platform it's an
ecosystem it's scaled for us it allowed
us to integrate and it allowed our
product development team to get out and
come up with new ideas and I never had
to tell them technology doesn't do good
say yeah we can do that the second part
is there are a lot of ways to get there
right I showed you one of the
architectures that we implemented on
this journey but it's an I would
encourage you to experiment it's easy to
set up it's easy to run through it
it's easy to tear down and try something
different think of it as a journey and
think of it as one that's actually kind
of fun to go on the other piece is for
me personally that efficiency and the
accuracy that was so important my
feeling I could get my team motivated
every single day and say today we're
gonna make it better we're gonna build
on everything we had it was all there
and we had a way to share those
learnings with each other once again
thank you very much for attending this
session and thank you again to all of
our presenters from Chevron Hitachi and
Nissen thank you
[Music]